l'idée est de prélever des cellules des
cellules souches ou des cellules
musculaires sur un animal vivant ou de
travailler avec des lignées cellulaires
immortelles dans tous les cas ces
cellules se multiplient dans un
bio-réacteur un bioréacteur de grande
taille
c'est cellules sont plongées dans un
milieu de culture et on obtient à la fin
du processus une grande quantité de
fibres musculaires et donc mon exposé va
être sous la forme de question il y a
d'abord des quelques questions éthiques
au départ si le nombre d'animaux
d'élevage doit diminuer en raison de
développement de la viande de culture
que va devenir la biodiversité animale
et qu'en est-il des animaux qui vont
rester qui vont être prélevés
régulièrement pour fournir des cellules
si on utilise des lignées cellulaires
immortelles on rentre dans la
problématique des OGM en ce qui concerne
le milieu de culture quelle est sa
composition il doit apporter des
hormones des facteurs de croissance
jusqu'à présent la viande de culture
vendue à Singapour contient du sérum de
vos fœtal comment recycler ce milieu de
sûr pour diminuer les coûts
en ce qui concerne la multiplication
cellulaire la question de la stabilité
ou de la dérive génétique doit être
opposée et doit être étudiée enfin c'est
un processus consommateur d'énergie
puisqu'il faut porter les incubateurs à
température physiologique
en ce qui concerne le produit final y
a-t-il des résidus éventuels du milieu
de culture dans ce produit final quelle
est la composition de ce produit final
quelles sont ses qualités sanitaires
nutritionnelles et sensorielles et tous
les scientifiques qui ont publié de
nombreux articles indiqués sur cette
diapositive se pose ce genre de
questions il y a une autre question
est-ce que est-ce de la viande non selon
la législation européenne il y a des
avis variables selon les pays pour des
raisons politiques et ou religieuses la
FAO préfère parler de
sel base full c'est à dire aliments à
base de cellules les dégâts des
végétariens pensent que c'est de la
viande mais les consommateurs brésiliens
que nous avons interrogés pensent le
contraire et en ce qui concerne les
experts de la viande ils insistent sur
l'idée qu'il y a autant de différence
entre le vin et le jus de raisin qu'il y
a entre la viande et le muscle puisqu’il
y a une étape importante de maturation
c'est à dire de transformation du muscle
en viande qu'il faut prendre en compte
dans ce processus
une autre question est-ce bon pour
l'environnement il est tout à fait vrai
qu'il y a une étude de l'Université
d'Oxford en 2011 qui a répondu oui à
cette question mais depuis il y a
d'autres études qui auront un petit peu
tempéré cette conclusion
par exemple en 2015 il a été dit que
l'impact environnemental est plus élevé
pour la viande de culture que pour la
viande de poulet ou pour d'autres
sources de protéines il y a une plus
grande consommation d'énergie par
rapport à la viande bovine et cet
article la contredit la première étude
quand on regarde les gaz à effet de
serre qui sont produits par ce processus
c'est essentiellement du CO2 qui
s'accumule dans l'atmosphère au bout de
100 de 100-300 ans etc alors que
l'élevage comme chacun sait produit
essentiellement du méthane qui disparaît
plus vite de l'atmosphère un rapport
privé dont qui a été publié en partie
récemment montre que l'impact carbone
varie d'un facteur 5 suivant le type
d'énergie et insiste sur l'air certitude
de ces estimations il y a un autre
article de synthèse qui indique que
finalement il y a beaucoup d'étapes qui
ont été oubliées pour estimer l'impact
environnemental de la viande de culture
et certains insistent sur
non seulement la production de gaz à
effet de serre l'utilisation des terres
l'utilisation d'eau mais aussi sur les
services écosystémiques rendus par
l'élevage et il faut bien entendu
prendre ses services en considération
dans la comparaison
qu'en pensent les consommateurs là aussi
c'est extrêmement difficile parce qu'on
interroge les consommateurs sur un
produit qui n'existe pas donc finalement
quelque part
les réponses de ces consommateurs ne
sont pas très fiables néanmoins il faut
faire attention comment les questions
sont posées si vous demandez aux
consommateurs est-ce que vous êtes prêt
à goûter la majorité va répondre oui
est-ce que vous êtes prêts en consommer
régulièrement la majorité va répondre
non donc il y a une acceptation sociale
très variable selon de nombreux facteurs
et la plupart des consommateurs dans
leur grande majorité
voudraient que le prix de ce produit
soit inférieur ou égal à celui de la
viande conventionnelle
la majorité des consommateurs pensent
que a priori se produit ne serait ni ça
ni savoureux ni naturelle les
consommateurs sont sensibles à des
arguments individuels sur leur santé sur
le plaisir de manger et bien que les
consommateurs notamment français
s'interrogent sur les problèmes éthiques
et environnementaux de l'élevage cela ne
suffit pas toujours à convaincre puisque
seulement 18 à 26% des mêmes répondants
pensent que la viande de culture est une
solution et c'est trois portions et donc
relativement faible
j'insisterai sur l'importance de la
communication et même si c'est pas le
cas de nos deux entreprises ici
présentes le combat anti-élevage reste
une motivation de certains industriels